[Music]
in northern Lithuania near the city of
shulay hundreds of thousands of crosses
sit on a hill now representing Bertha
Lithuanian identity and Christian
diversion this site of pilgrimage offers
peace to those who visit this is the
hill of crosses
the tradition of leaving crosses began
in 1831 to commemorate those who had
fallen in a rebellion against Russia
[Music]
people still leave crosses today
[Music]
this bright colourful temple located in
southern India wasn't put on earth just
to catch the eye it's also one of the
largest Hindu houses of worship
welcome to the sri ranganathaswamy
temple it is dedicated to the Hindu god
of ranganatha a reclining form of the
Hindu deity Vishnu
but this relaxed looking God is one of
the highest levels of Hindu idols the
temple which has over six miles of walls
and over a hundred buildings is one of
the five important pilgrimage sites
along the river Kaveri for devotees of
ranganatha the temple itself is a beacon
of the uniquely South Indian Providian
style of architecture its temples are
adorned with pyramid shaped towers made
from sandstone soapstone or granite the
first construction on this site dates
back nearly 700 years it grew and grew
into the wonder that it is today
a site that will surely settle any
pilgrims wandering soul
[Music]
there are 33,000 traditional temples in
Thailand but with its majestic white
exterior what Ron kun is anything but
ordinary
[Music]
every part of what Ron kun is unique the
entrance is lined with ghoulish traffic
cones
ghostly heads hang from trees and arms
reach up to meet you as you cross the
bridge to this architecture Lee curious
place of worship what Ron Koons most
distinguishing feature is its
untraditional white color chosen by the
artist to represent purity the
sprinkling of glass mosaics are an
emblem of enlightenment while the
mirrors show off Buddha's wisdom shining
through the universe contrasting the
white is a gold building the ornate rest
room is covered in gold leaf symbolizing
the idea of the minds fixation on wealth
and material possessions
while the temple is visually stunning
and attracts thousands of tourists from
around the world when it was first
completed it received negative attention
the Thai government monks and other
artists said it wasn't tired as it was a
departure from the traditional due to
the symbols embracing pop culture found
throughout the grounds
despite that the building stands
defiantly as an emblem of Thai art for a
modern world pink towers and giant
dragons sounds like a scene from a fairy
tale but in this case it's not in the
Sam Braun district sits one of
Thailand's most unique temples
what some prawn is a pink shrine
dedicated to the Buddhist faith and
measures 260 feet or 80 metres high
representing the age of Buddha when he
died while the temple is known for the
giant encircling dragon its meaning
remains a mystery Bhuvana Bhutto the
founder of the temple was inspired to
create the hollow dragon building during
a seven-day fasting meditation
construction took only five years
visitors can climb the stairs of the
17-story temple to touch the dragon's
beard or they can climb inside the belly
of the beast this temple is a must visit
for people looking to discover something
truly one-of-a-kind made entirely of
wood without a single nail the sanctuary
of truth in Pattaya Thailand is a
modern-day marvel built using ancient
carving techniques this religious shrine
has been under construction since 1981
and it isn't scheduled to be completed
any time soon it was commissioned by a
Thai millionaire who spent his fortune
on projects like this he wanted to keep
ancient wood building techniques alive
the building towers 375 feet and looks
out over the cursed it's four wings are
dedicated to Thai Cambodian Chinese and
Indian iconography a team of 250 wood
carvers have created ornate images of
religious and philosophical significance
throughout the structure the sanctuary
of truth is considered in the art
instillation religious shrine and
cultural monument all in one
although the creator has passed away and
weren't have an opportunity to see his
celestial masterpiece completed the work
continues according to his specific
plans
[Music]
in Thailand there are over 40,000
buddhist temples but there's only one
that looks quite like this completed in
2004 wat pile a.m. is a collection of
temples and statues located on Koh Samui
Thailand second-largest island these are
active temples in a tranquil place where
quiet reflection is encouraged an
appropriate attire is a must
one of the most eye-catching figures is
the statue of the Buddha which is 30
meters high and painted in bright red
white and gold
the main statue at Wat pile a.m. is the
Buddhist goddess of compassion and mercy
guanine here she's represented with 18
arms which shows her ability to help
many people in need at once the temple
is surrounded by a lake filled with
hungry fish visitors who make a donation
to the temple are given a bag of fish
food people also buy fish and turtles at
the local food market and release them
into the lake Buddhists consider it an
act of spiritual merit and the fish and
turtles do too
[Applause]
[Music]
in northern Italy in the foothills of
the Alps a collection of temples
dedicated to the human spirit sit 100
feet below ground built in secret over a
period of 15 years
this is dumb amor the temples of
humankind
[Music]
[Music]
to honor this mausoleum in shiraz iran
is like stepping into the holiest of
light shows
the shot Sheriff which roughly
translates to king of the light in
Persian is a funerary monument and
mosque a beautiful holy place for
thousands of Muslim worshippers
the structure is made of multicolored
pieces of tile and glass and is
considered to be the third most
important pilgrimage site in Iran
initially started around 900 AD as a
burial site for an important Shia Muslim
figure the mosque continued to be
expanded and improved the decision to
adorn the mosque with its iconic
Mirrorball decoration came from Queen
toshka tune in the 14th century she
wanted the mosque to intensify any light
a thousand times over in homage to the
mosques name although meant to be a holy
shrine and important pilgrimage location
for Shia Muslims people of any faith can
marvel at the mosques immense beauty the
mesquita has always been a spiritual
place but has not always been occupied
by the same religion nowhere else in the
world will you find a cathedral built
inside the walls of a mosque
originally the site of a temple to the
Roman god Janus the mesquita was built
as a mosque after Cordoba came under
Moorish rule in the late 7th century
then in 1236 the city of Cordoba came
under Christian rule and the mesquita
was converted to a church four centuries
later a cathedral was constructed in its
center and it became a home for the
town's Roman Catholics while the
cathedral is an example of classic
Catholic Baroque architecture the
majority of the mosquitoes construction
is a result of the work of Islamic
architects features like 856 columns and
symmetrical arches give the illusion of
infinite space these elements are
examples of why the mesquita is
considered one of the greatest
accomplishments in Islamic architecture
in the world today it is a unesco world
heritage site over a million people
visit every year and after all its
history it is now seen as a site of
religious significance to both Catholics
and Muslims
you
you
[Music]